at a time when the world is facing its
perhaps biggest global financial crisis
at a time when g20 of the world's
biggest countries are getting together
to solve that crisis we are lucky to
have with us mr. Nye and Chanda a former
journalist and the author of a of what I
think is probably the best book on
globalization called bound together he
is from Yale mr. Chanda my first
question would be given that we are now
in the middle of this crisis which seems
at at this moment to be somewhat
moderating although not ending where you
have 20 countries getting together to
fix it how does this crisis stand in the
entire fifty thousand years of history
that you have studied on globalization
well the fifty thousand years of history
has only very few hundred years of last
century which actually showed saw the
economic integration taking place so it
is very new phenomenon one of the
earliest crisis you one knows is the
tulip mania in holland which wire is a
big speculation on the value of Q lee
bulb but that was a domestic almost
european at maximum issue which led to a
loss of lot of people's wealth but more
recent one was the 1997 crisis in asian
crisis which led to collapse of two
governments led to collapse of many
companies and unemployment of millions
of workers but this one is perhaps the
most globalized crisis in the sense that
what started in Wall Street has now
spread to the whole world and that's the
reason why 20 countries of the major
countries of the world have been brought
together for the first time in history
to actually try to find a solution to
this crisis all through Prime Minister
Manmohan Singh also said recently that
this crisis is the beginning of a
balance of power to emerging countries
like India China and prayers
now I do not want to be so specific but
in the entire canvas that you have
studied have such events happened
earlier where a major problem brought
worlds together a new order was created
yes I think that one of the first thing
was the Treaty of Westphalia in 1648 in
Europe the rise of national States they
had to find a way of preserving peace so
these national States of Europe came
together to accept the notion that the
state sovereignty should be respected
and you cannot just go into somebody
else's country and change the government
stuff like that and in fact
interestingly in 1880's the first global
conference was held in washington and
that conference was to determine the
time zone of the world the world was at
that time they had railway lines and
telegraph and they moved fast but the
people did not know what time was in any
part of the world and so some 27
countries gathered in Washington to
determine that art should be divided
into 24 hour zone so that was the first
global governance issue that was raised
the people who have created this crisis
or who are being blamed for this crisis
are mere puppets in my opinion of
technology and innovation the
adventurers so to speak the people who
drive countries forward who take
civilizations forward but in this
particular case when when I observe them
carefully these people can be classified
as traders because they are there to
make a profit they can be classified as
preachers because they are preaching
things like democracy globalization
finance there are adventurers when they
devise new products which nobody can
understand perhaps not even themselves
and their lawyers and they are also
warriors trying to take over one another
you know expand their kingdoms and do
you see in this crisis a narrowing down
of all these four categories into one
unit called let's say the deviant
speculator well I think is you have a
very colorful way of describing the
perpetrators of the present crisis you
can look at it that way but basically
the root of it is the desire to make
profit so everything else is secondary
they are not going to preach free market
if the free market does not enhance
their profit they are not going to
probably from proposed democracy if that
is not going to help them financially so
the bottle of it is the desire to make
profit and then you have other
motivations that come in including what
you said the warrior spirit of actually
watching into other companies acquiring
Marjorie going to another country to
establish a big operation there so these
are can can be called kind of warrior
like activities but again at the root of
this is the desire to maximize profit
you wouldn't call these people the
Genghis Khan of the 21st century no
Genghis Khan actually gangis khan has
now been historians are revising his
role in history he is no longer seen as
the red destroyer
the Mongol Empire maintained peace for
you know some half a century and leading
the Silk Road that connected in China to
Europe as the safest route to travel for
shredders so it was during the Mongol
Empire the trade flourished I am still a
little confused on this the fact that
this trader wants to make money lies at
the root but how to make money there is
the warrior in him there is the
adventurer in him you disagree with this
no I don't disagree but in order the
warrior the definition of warrior is
essentially to defeat an enemy and that
enemy often was enemy of another country
another government that you defeat error
to take physical control of the
territory of the people but now that all
territories are control so the fight now
is mental it's in at a level of when you
press a click a button and billions of
dollars flow here and there you don't
think that imagery was no it doesn't
work because the Warriors are still very
much present you just look at
Afghanistan look at Iraq look at indian
navy in the Somalian waters and so these
are warriors and they're performing a
task in terms of preserving peace or
recording territory ok I'll shift the
topic a bit one of the reasons for the
growth of civilizations and
globalization has been transported now
so far it has been a very smooth journey
until the last one year when oil prices
have shorter and although they are down
now it is not they may rise again there
is a pressure on oil how do you see the
future of globalization without
transport this is actually very very
interesting and important question
because history of globalization shows
that with the
new technology allowing for faster
transportation more volume
transportation has increased the
connections and interdependence so from
sailship to steamship as a big change
and from steamship to containership in
the 1970s is a big change jumbo jet was
a big change now all this use fossil
fuel and fossil fuel is a depleting
quantity today the price may be lower
because the demand is down but it is
certain the prices are going to go up
because ultimately the supply of fossil
fuel is declining and the demand is
rising so but when the price of oil goes
up transportation will be more expensive
and that certainly would crimp the kind
of globalization we have seen this the
supply chain economy that has developed
where tiny parts are produced in many
countries they are shipped to one place
to be assembled into your product and so
even the bluefin tuna fish which is
caught in the New England waters in the
United States are flown to Tokyo to be
sliced by the sushi chefs then they
flown back to New York to serve in the
restaurants there so if a fish has
traveled 16 20,000 miles before count
your plate and that is the kind of
excesses that we have been performing
because we have at cheap transportation
and that is going to end so maybe next
thing we'll know the sushi chefs have
been flown to New York to station there
and chop their fish right in New York
rather than fly them to Tokyo and bring
them
how will this impact globalization will
it will it not mean localization or
immigration or some new way away from
the traditional way that we look at
globalization it I think it is going to
lead to more regionalization
localization is impossible because no
country can produce something in telling
within the zone border and make it at a
price that people invite you can make
t-shirt in the United States it will
cost sixty dollars but if you take us
textile a cotton to China and make it
there it will be five dollars so the
question is that that kind of supply
chain economy would perhaps become more
regional so that the distance is
traveled by goods would be less but
division of labor disintegrated
production distributed production is
something that is economically so
important to keep the price down I don't
see that this can change unless there is
the absolute catastrophic decline in
fossil through ellen and shipping stops
so just as an aside so does this mean
that West Asia which has the oil
reserves could finally be the new
financial new global leader in terms of
control of resources that drive
globalization it will be a new global
leader until the point alternative
technology alternative energy has been
produced which knocks it out remember
that the until the discovery of
petroleum in the 1830s it was well oil
which was used to light homes to provide
illumination LOL provide the fuel to it
which to cook and so who else had a
lease of life when Petrolia was found in
philadelphia so it there may be another
time when somebody comes out with the
technology which produces solar cells at
a dark cheap price so the solar cell
technology would replace
fossil fuel in a big way and that would
reduce the importance of Middle East one
last set of questions and this is on
preaching religion God in my opinion
organized religion has failed society
and yet you have large group of people
who are constantly preaching their
little religions in fact there are
40,000 religions operating in the world
today don't you see this as an anti
globalizing tendency rather than
globalization as you have mentioned in
your book it has always been the case
that attempt by one group to Priscilla
ties to win over convert has different
kind of impact some has made stuff
resistance throughout history
missionaries have been executed by
sovereigns in Japan 16g admission it is
executed in Vietnam there are hundreds
of cases where missionaries are executed
there are other cases of missionaries
succeeded in converting the natives they
went to convert what is happening is
that the world's major Abrahamic
religion Islam and Christianity they
have a huge pool of resources and so
their drive to facilities is meeting
some resistance in local cultures so it
is the kind of action counteraction it
is inevitable that when people feel that
their traditional culture is threatened
by something coming from outside they
band together to resist and so this
threat from the outside is increasing
because of the ease of transportation
communication and wealth available to
solve these groups so this is
privatizing therefore anti-globalization
would you know Pro through the
transition has been part of
globalization because if you think that
this religions of the desert
Christianity and Islam now we have three
billion people in the world they
converted how did it happen this is the
globalization of religion but this is
sing some resist resistance last
question what is the religion of
tomorrow democracy globalization climate
change are these the new religions of
tomorrow how is does God have a place i
think the god that is going to have
increasing place in people's concern is
the environment because when you know
when if when you cannot breathe then you
realize the importance of air and until
that happens you go in a many ways and
there are places where you cannot
breathe they said my god what are we
done so i think that awareness that we
are how are we have is finite world and
finite resources air and water and we
are we are being very profligate in
using those and so I think the
increasingly environment is becoming the
new sort of religion of people and
people are going to be converted to that
because it is their life that is fig
threatened so we go back all the way
5,000 years ago when the religion was
born with fire water and the elements
right and after all this evolution we
come back to fire water air thank you
very much mr. Manchanda it's been great
talking to you thank you